[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
blouson noir il a regardé quoi
aujourd'hui il est passé sur youtube non
je dis c'est youtube le jeudi sur
youtube rappelez vous la semaine
dernière je vous ai ramené des images de
youtube heures beauté ouais on adore les
cja lisez dans les coupes de cheveux
malgré qu'il ait à coupe de cheveux de
bain gérard jugnot
il était aussi spécialisé dans l'effet
de surprise surtout au moment du riz
ville entre son ancienne coupe de
cheveux et sa nouvelle coupe de cheveux
il a recommencé sauf qu'il a tenu à nous
passer un petit coucou en plus à à ne
pas utiliser si vous n'avez pas les
cheveux trèbes l'entraidé coloré mais ça
je ne le sais pas et on le saura dans 40
minutes à tout à l'heure
coucou
[Musique]
je pense à beaucoup changé s'étaient
soldés mais c'est la même si le même
bail alors c'est la même tête sauf qu'en
avril à rajouter un petit peu de
produits ça se voit pas comment ça va se
passer
merci bon alors comme vous savez son
concept à lui ses balais coupe de
cheveux mais pas que il teste aussi
beaucoup de nouveaux produits
malheureusement il n'a pas capté qu'il
ya certains produits qui n'étaient pas
du tout adapté la calvitie
petit bonus parce que je sais que ça va
vous faire plaisir
le coloriste assure le haut du crâne là
où il n'ya presque plus de cheveux ah
bah oui ça colore le crâne
[Applaudissements]
le gars il te parle on dirait qu'il a
une touffe de ouf
comme il est persuadé d'avoir des
chevaux de malades j'adore mais
justement vous allez voir c'est pas
seulement youtuber beauté non c'est
aussi un magicien capillaires à c'est le
seul gars qui s'est passé de la coupe de
bruce willis à celle de clovis le roi
des francs en deux coups de ciseaux je
vais faire un brushing et je vous
retrouve tout de suite pour le résultat
final
et voici le résultat final
[Applaudissements]
copé qui sérieux regard il est outré
quoi mais l'apache ans elle a l'air
gentil bon et sa chaîne youtube
fonctionne alors comme tout l'échiquier
fonctionne il est un petit peu voulu
montrer les coulisses de cette chaîne
alors face caméra c'est quelqu'un de
super souriant super mesuré mais par
contre en coulisses il est très
facilement
énervé le gars ne doit pas être très
structuré il est bien mais je vous
propose qu'on commence tout il est pas
mal là tu peux arrêter de faire du bruit
parce que j'entends du bruit là c'est
bien mais bien et cette semaine j'ai
aussi fait la découverte d'un coach en
commandite d'un coach en développement
personnel
adacore voilà alors en plus de ça c'est
aussi un homme viril c'est super en fait
parce que galaade aborde des sujets
heureusement qu'il aborde ces sujets
parce qu'on n'y aurais pas pensé tout
seul aujourd'hui vos réponses question
cruciale comment avoir une barbe de
trois jours
alors tout d'abord cinq essais c'est un
truc courant mais si t'as pas de barbe
t'es dans la merde
non
alors aujourd'hui on va parler du style
pas we you
[Musique]
donc on va voir comment on peut
transformer ce regard rouillard
justement plus ténébreux donc fait petit
compression entre des jouets des
sourcils
tu vois comme ça chez vous lui qui nous
a trouvé là c'est nobel rim rim est bon
la daurade aussi vous avez là même où
ses conseils en parle comme vous cyril
quand vous faites la cigarette et hier
soir le gros événement du paf alors
c'était pas le râteau que mamie kelly en
live un nid la spéciale pains au
chocolat grâce à un nul en live mais en
coulisses elle vous à elle vous kiffe
sachez le à bâle a l'air au courant vous
êtes toujours sur le bail ou pas ben
j'essaye mais du coulage
il ya beaucoup de questions je vous dit
tout à l'heure sur des questions vérité
qui parle de telli andreas et voilà
comment pas alors je suis là pour ça et
ben voilà alors hier soir justement
l'événement du pape ne s'était pas à ces
deux événements dont c'était surtout la
présence de cyril hanouna dans strike ah
oui alors merci à vous parce que cela
fait un très beau score ait dit ça très
bien montée donc merci à versailles pour
les audiences alors dans strike on voit
que vous êtes bon en tout mais surtout
en bonne foi enfin comment dire quand
vous avez fois une réponse vous hésitez
pas du tout à le reconnaître
enfin presque avatar ou un collègue un
chabbat j'aurai la bataille 45 secondes
alambic jabadao corrigan
pour hiba quand ils gagnent c'est
exactement ce que j'avais c'est
exactement ce que j'avais bon après ça
j'ai aussi aller dans la rue à on a des
bases et des questions en français ça
comme vous le savez le prix de l'essence
à la pompe à huawei complètement
exposées du coup les français
aujourd'hui hésite entre faire le plein
de la 306 ou s'acheter un building
voilà le tout pour eux je me suis
demandé si offrir un plein d'essence
rendrait le sourire aux français
ah ouais alors chercher leur poser une
question simple dans la rue s'il avait
la réponse je le referais soit un plein
d'essence soit un an d'essence offert et
bizarrement malgré la valeur du cadeau
ils n'étaient pas ou fait pas la
question est simple combien d'ex femmes
à benjamin castaldi
je dirais 7 aces et une bonne réponse
mais on devra propre tué cheikh faye ne
pas les fautes et ton plein d'essence
est juste là bas ça c'est ton plein
d'essence et ton cadeau du coup il faut
que tu partes avec et rapidement vu que
c'est des premières fois ça c'est ton
plein d'essence
mam est déjà âgé que de bras benjamin
castaldi a perdu 15 kilos grâce à son
régime comme j'aime combien en at il
repris depuis
[ __ ] assez chaud 10 kg c'est la bonne
réponse ouais j'ai gagné ma gueule il a
attend voir comment je te laisse aller
je peux vous prendre cette mère de
regarder en malaisie les fuck votre jeu
quel est l'âge exact d'isabelle moribond
4,83 c'est une bonne réponse j'avais ppm
besoin de gagner en descente
jadot normalement arrive juste ici ces
blagues
non mais je passe à moi avec ça
du coup ça leur rend pas vraiment le
sourire soit votée
adresse très très fort